and we'll take one more from an email
from Paulo
Oh Paulo from Brazil Maya who was who
was the weirdest kid you remember from
your childhood and what did they do that
made them weird the weird escape from my
childhood oh dude I'll tell you who it
was bro why you know I am when you said
that question I thought to myself I
don't didn't know anybody mm-hmm
which made me the weird kid mm-hmm like
I was the one people thought was weird
I remember in an in in middle school not
even in elementary school I lived in
Minnesota and the kids used to say throw
not snowballs at my head but ice rocks
oh wow and they just used to as hard as
it can just throw it at my [ __ ] head
why you collected him or something I
don't know one collects ice rocks right
okay what do you mean you'll remain [ __ ]
my bad man I had an icicle collection at
my heart hear you say you were the weird
guy I guess do you collect and people
were like no dude no these two do it
violently I'm sorry man I would never do
that to you dude if you were my friend
I know you wouldn't I probably would've
put you in like one of those little
wagons you know there's red wagons yeah
I know the right way it's a Chinese
buddy on the side of it and I were to
hook you to my bike dude you all around
town oh that's nice like you you have a
rickshaw for me Yeah right yeah and then
I just ten years yeah all right that's
great or bow it people and stuff people
through you be through chocolates Yeah
right like I'm a deity oh yeah that's
really nice we go on a big chocolate
ride every day sweet people come out and
wish you well and give you baked goods
yeah and if you like them and they're
gonna have good luck and if you don't
like them it's not gonna go too well for
them yeah
so it's all up to you yeah it's up to me
chocolate rider who was the kid at your
who do we have we had this dude named
Brian Brian Purvis at first wig I ever
you know and they don't have him anymore
they have a couple left I think outside
of maybe Cincinnati but he was like the
first white kid that ever wanted to be
black and they'd never seen it before
and they put him in a mentally
handicapped classes because they thought
he's a mentally handed mentally
challenged is that what they used to do
with wiggers yeah yeah well they didn't
know they'd never seen it before yeah
they put him in there Wow because they
had people that were really you know
people that were just you know didn't
know what was going on yeah have people
blind people that were you know freebase
victims all kind of stuff like that yeah
you just had Brian's Purvis just
dribbling an invisible basketball just
wearing a [ __ ] Charlotte Hornets polo
starter pullover apex and just [ __ ]
you know blow him in a [ __ ] yelling
at people yeah like oh man we don't know
what he has is Brian still an
institution or he's out no he's got
somebody sent me a picture on the other
day I think he's in prison somewhere is
in jail or in or out of jail but yeah I
wish him well he's a nice kid he still
looks the same at nice highs I remember
that he had pretty eyes for a young
fella that had a rare disease you know
yeah yeah but he was one of the wildest
locally you know people didn't know what
was going on we don't know you know yes
science doesn't know yeah and he was
just you know nothing was wrong he was
just you know he bought Shaquille
O'Neal's rap album and he just watched
Space Jam all the time yeah and he
listened to boys to men he would just
wake it up
I had a friend named Brady mmm-hmm he
was the neighborhood kid and with one
hand he could pull a stop sign out of
the ground
oh gosh he has like a subhuman strength
right and then but he was also kind of
[ __ ] like you would ask him a
question he wouldn't even know what
you're saying oh yeah yeah like how how
are you and you go and you just pull it
on the ground right yeah yeah I remember
him I used to use him to break into
houses oh gee Wow because he was to get
marijuana oh wow I would break into
people's houses to healer of mice and
marijuana
he just that's a funny movie let's make
that movie to crowdfund yeah did we
making [ __ ] dude we're barely gonna
[ __ ] get this episode